also katrin eigendorf hat gerade gesagt
dass der ukrainische präsident see
lynskey sich zu einer wirklichen
führungsfigur entwickelt und das hängt
auch damit zusammen dass er immer wieder
betont im land bleiben zu wollen obwohl
die usa ihm jetzt wohl möglich eine
angebot gemacht haben sich in sicherheit
zu bringen wir wollen jetzt darüber
sprechen und zwar mit unserem
korrespondenten in washington da ist es
jetzt nachts wir begrüßen alle materie
sind hallo emma
ja schon morgen nach deutschland hallo
was können sie uns darüber sagen elmar
selensky lehnt ein fluchthilfe angebot
der usa ab
die washington post hat gemeldet dass
tatsächlich die usa solche angebote an
know me als lenski gemacht hat man hat
ihnen eigentlich seite seit monaten
schon beraten was passiert eigentlich
wenn man hat ihm auch sehr bewusst
abgeraten zur münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vor einigen wochen
zu fliegen er hat es trotzdem gemacht
und jetzt gibt es eben das stehende
angebot der usa ihn zu evakuieren er hat
bisher dieses angebot abgelehnt seine
familie befindet sich an einem
unbekannten ort in sicherheit so heißt
es hier in washington aber die lenski
selber will eben vor ort bleiben um den
widerstand zu koordinieren aber die usa
haben dieses angebot eben gemacht weil
sie glauben in dem moment wo er gefangen
genommen würde wäre es für leute die mir
putin einfach eben eine regierung zu
installieren ein marionettenregime
gewissermaßen deswegen ist das eine
letzte option das entstehen das angebot
wie genau das stattfinden würde das
wissen wir nicht aber
vielleicht noch ein anderes thema und
zwar zum thema sanktionen nach der eu
haben ja auch die usa weitere gegen
russland verhängt welche sanktionen sind
das was können sie bewirken
ja man hat eher symbolisch wladimir
putin seinem außenminister sergei lavrov
sowie auch den verteidigungsminister und
dem generalstabschef auf die liste der
special days it nationals gesetz die stn
liste bedeutet im grunde genommen dass
diese personen ihre guthaben eingefroren
bekommen in den usa sofern sie welche
abend das keine amerikaner und
amerikanische firmen in irgendeiner form
mit ihnen geschäfte machen können auf
dieser liste stehen normalerweise auch
terroristen terrorismus unterstützer
drogendealer und anderes steht auch
baschar al assad ein staatschef auf
dieser liste drauf das hat in diesem
fall der russischen führung eigentlich
eher eine symbolische bedeutung weil die
vermögensverhältnisse so verschachtelt
sind dass es schwer ist tatsächlich
diese sanktionen auch dann durchzusetzen
oder wladimir putin so sagt man habe
überhaupt kein bankkonto aber ist ein
wichtiges signal die usa sind auch der
meinung dass man russland vom swift
internationalen banken
kommunikationssystemen ab grenzen sollte
isolieren sollte die europäer tun sich
ganz offenbar schwer mit dieser
entscheidung und solange werden die usa
und die eu keine vor allen dingen
finanziell weiter unterstützen der
präsident hat 350 millionen dollar
direkthilfe nochmal munition und waffen
bürgerliche und obendrein 6,4 milliarden
dollar vom amerikanischen kongress
beantragt um bei humanitären maßnahmen
für die
ukrainische bevölkerung zu unterstützen
also die usa wollen unterstützen und
helfen wo es geht danke für die
aktuellen informationen live aus
washington war das el mati wissen dank
schirm